[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh it's always great to take a spin
around los angeles sports wise with bill
plaschke la times columnist and of
course one of the stars of espn's
around the horn let me start with the
chargers bill
they got their franchise quarterback
do they have their coach no no
he he he iced his own kicker last night
um
no they they need to anthony lynn's a
great guy and everybody in town loves
them
but it's time for a new voice a new
fresh look a new uh
you know take on things and and and they
need somebody to coach this young
quarterback
because this kid's a star herbert's a
star and in this town
that means a ton and last night he again
he proved what you know what he can do
he's
he's gonna behind him this team could
get could become
actually an la team which is the first
same time i think they've ever i've ever
said that
but then you have the rams the best team
in town and
they've kind of been under the radar it
feels like uh because this wasn't the
sean mcvay jared goff offense
high-powered
quarterback whisper they've been leading
with their defense here in their running
game how dangerous do you think the rams
will become playoff time
well i think durants can go to the super
bowl i mean you look at the nfc and what
what else is out there
unless of course i heard drew brees is
coming back but if breeze is not healthy
and
green bay's defense is suspected rants
to go to super bowl but they're just
again this is a town of star
he's more of a game manager now and
that's working for them and cam makers
is great at running back that's a
revelation
but you know they don't have the star
but never see us never see his face
that's why justin herbert
that was such a big deal last night and
such a big deal to have them in the new
stadium and such a big deal
this is the best coaching they're going
to get they're going to get rid of
anthony lynn this will be the best
coaching vacancy in the nfl
well yeah i mean you have your franchise
quarterback and that's what
all of these coaches are looking for you
want that guy got a rookie contract here
and then you can build around them and
they do have
talent on that it's not like joe burrow
going to the bengals
justin herbert went to a charger team
that has just
underachieved and always had uh injuries
they have great great defense they have
great young talent
they got a great quarterback they have
all the ingredients to contend and of
course you gotta they're
in a bad division and that's gonna be
tough but i just think it's a real
it's a real plum job for someone how
about jim harbaugh
get jim harbaugh back in the nfl i'm
serious everybody laughs about that
he's a pretty good nfl coach he's got a
lot of la
san diego roots bring him back yeah
i look it's not far-fetched i mean i
even brought up well
you know if it doesn't work out at
michigan just have him go to the detroit
lions you know just
keep him in state there but you know i
i think he'll eventually go back to the
nfl but i don't think he's ready to go
now
uh i want to ask you about the clipper
situation because this is one of those
wait a minute
what happened and jerry west involved in
this and you have somebody saying that
jerry said
promised a payoff of what two and a half
million dollars to deliver
kawhi leonard to the clippers why is
this coming out
now and is there any validity to it i
know the nba is investigating well it's
coming out now because the guy filed the
lawsuit against
jerry and the clippers and the the jerry
west ought to counter sue the guy for
fraud
because kawhi leonard hasn't been worth
the effort that they put into getting
him so far he needs a
he's got a lot more to prove out here no
i mean you pay 2.5 million dollars to
sway a guy to come to your team and you
don't get out of the second round again
come on um but i just think i i'm back
in the law i can't imagine
that the logo would need one of the
greatest executives the grants executive
of all time in the nba if you ask me
would need help in trying to recruit a
player i can't imagine that i heard the
clippers did a lot of things
to try to recruit kawhi i can't imagine
they would do something like that
but even that even that it is so what's
what's the nba going to do
find them draft picks they don't have
any draft picks 10 million dollars
bomber's got that much in his in his
sofa cushions uh
i just think this is a this is going to
be quickly become a non-story and if it
does become a story i'm backing the logo
on this
i've always got the logos back yeah he's
one of my idols i i just i think that's
why i
took note of the story because you know
we always look at jerry jerry gets his
man when he wants him
and to get kawhi leonard and that's why
when you had somebody saying hey
he promised me two and a half million
dollars to deliver
imagine that i just can't imagine and
some of the stuff the guy was saying
that he was the advice he was giving
jerry was tell kawhi you won him tell
kauai the clippers are going to be good
i don't think i said if i said that's
advice gary really needed
so i think this is this isn't much to do
about nothing and it's a dumb rule
anyway
it's a do do you agree it's a dumb rule
this intermediary thing everybody does
that when they try to get jobs for other
people everybody recruits everybody like
that
yeah it's i don't think it's a stupid
rule college is littered with uh
guys who do this and and that's their
living uh the lakers situation
uh how much better are they going to be
this season than uh last season
i can't believe i'm going to say this
they're going to be better they're going
to be a lot better i mean they're going
to be they're
deeper they're better going to be better
defensively i mean i see
i don't see anybody challenging them at
all and and the clippers
i think are going to be worse than last
year and and i think that this whole
chemistry thing really came up and bit
them and
it's all been exposed now and i think
the clippers is going to be worse
the lakers are going to be better i mean
and then this this horton tucker kid
it's been a real revelation there watch
for him
and uh better defensively
i don't know how they did it i don't
know how rob polinka did it he's been
i've criticized him so much in the past
and he actually made a championship team
better
yeah i think so too and i think just
that you know guys who maybe want to
play with lebron knowing that they got a
chance to win a championship here and
you get to play in los angeles you get
to play for the lakers here
schroeder they get younger uh gasal they
get better defensively
yeah and and he's a good passer and he
can
you know he can be outside and allow
anthony davis to kind of uh
have you know roam the floor you get rid
of playoff rondo
we only miss him when the playoffs take
place during the regular season
yeah not not as important but yeah i i
think that there's a
if i'm handicapping here i think if
golden state had stayed together bill
i really believe that they would be
right there with the lakers as the two
teams to beat
you know if you have draymond steph you
get wiseman as your number one pick
and klay thompson i mean that's still a
formidable lineup here
yeah but the anthony davis lebron james
they play together and
i've written i don't think lebron should
play at all until like april
i mean i think he's he's wiped out he
was
upset at the short break the nba took
and i think fans shouldn't be surprised
to see him he he's ripped load
management in the past he's going to be
all about lower management this year and
he should be
yeah but how do you do it though bill
how do you do it where the nba is
i mean you're just going to pay fines
that yes just yeah because it's all
about championships
and that's all the fans care about out
here that's all they that's all the
lakers care about
absolutely you pay fines you give lebron
heck you give them a month off i don't
care and i don't think the fans care
i think with one thing there's gonna be
no fans in the stands so nobody's gonna
hold up a ticket and say
i paid to see lebron james and he's not
she's not showing up today
this is a perfect year for that he's
obviously i mean you saw what his
comments were when he found out that the
nba was gonna come back december 22nd he
said oh bleep yeah
that's that's indicative of his body and
how
worn down he is and how worn down he can
be and i think the lakers need this team
and anthony
ready for spring and i think that's
that's what they're going to be uh
leading toward and i don't think anybody
can
is going to complain about that out here
yeah but you know how lebron is he's got
rabbit ears he hears everything he's
sensitive about this if somebody's going
to say hey
you've criticized these other guys with
load management and now you're doing the
same thing
well the reason he's criticized him dan
though he's always criticizing because
he said if somebody's in the stands
who's the first time they're going to
see me play i want to play for them
that's always been the basis of his
criticism
there is no more basis for that because
all the seats will be empty
so i think he's got his out and and i
support him on that
uh we uh you know i said we're not
armchair quarterbacks we're on
armchair ophthalmologist this weekend in
college football like the
the eye test with ohio state if usc
had been relevant the last couple of
years bill and been undefeated
would the committee be looking at would
there be an eye test involved with usc
tonight against oregon
absolutely dan they were there if they
hadn't gone into this season going 13
and 13
in the last 26 games having lost two
bowl games to big ten opponents
badly you know they they started the
year 18th in
in the cfp poll that's ridiculous i mean
how can
again i know what i know cincinnati's
gotta got a point and i understand all
that
but how can a team if usc wins tonight a
pack
an undefeated power five conference
champion
not getting into cip playoffs it's the
first time that's ever happened
and it's totally it's totally based on
the fact that the
that they their recency bias and
the fact that the pac-12 is so terrible
and all has such a terrible tv deal and
nobody sees them and
the conference is is not very deep and
so they're being held held back by
two things and neither of them is their
fault they belong if they win tonight
how do you keep a 6-0 usc team out of
the playoffs
they just they're not relevant they they
haven't been relevant bill
and i know and and that's not fair
that's that that's and again
i don't understand cincinnati's got a
point too usc would clock cincinnati on
on
on on on in a game uh usc
deserves to be any more in ohio state
does what's ohio state done
but they have they were 490 yards to
indiana but but they have a history here
recent history of being great
and they have a quarterback that
everybody knows they got
you know uh future first-round draft
picks there's talent there
and i understand they they haven't you
know their signature win was indiana
in columbus and they held on to win that
one and now 190 yards they gave up yeah
yeah but no i mean if the system is
flawed
but i don't know if anybody is going to
rectify this anytime soon it feels like
this is what
the tv executives want that is give
us the teams that people will watch
how can they not want to watch usc dan
and you know that they're
they're excited as anybody three fourth
quarter comebacks in the last minute in
the last one in the five games they're
holding that against them
i think it's ridiculous well they can
all blow somebody out though bill that's
the reason why they had these fourth
quarter comebacks is they're not putting
away
sub 500 teams here but they're winning
getting the bottom line as they're
winning games dan
they're under unbeaten six and oh an
undefeated usc team is not going to get
in the playoffs and that's ridiculous
you know and you you tell me if clemson
loses notre dame clemson gets in are you
kidding me
i mean that would have been usc's path
to get in they're not going to get ahead
of out of state
but if clemson loses and if the two
you're gonna put a two loss clemson team
in there
a two loss florida team in there a two
loss iowa state and team
to an undefeated pac-12 champion you're
fired up here
you're you're fired up well the path 12
is bad and i understand it's terrible
it's it's bad it's
and and they need a new commissioner and
they need a new look and they need a new
everything
but nonetheless undefeated
and it have you seen them play at all
have you stayed up at night and watched
them on
foundation don't do this don't do this
east coast
bias you guys don't stay up i i i have
two kids who went to usc half my
family went to usc yes i i watch
yeah well well my point is again they're
on nickelodeon or the comedy
they're not on they're not on regular
television oh no it's hard to find him
but
you know it's hard to find him yeah i i
just think it's i just think it's wrong
and i think
and and when it wouldn't that when that
one commissioner said go back to the bcs
bcs makes more sense than this to me it
honestly does yeah it honestly does
they they could have picked these four
teams at the start of the season yeah
this is a coordination
yes you you could have had and i at the
beginning of the year
when we were talking about the final
four i said alabama clemson
ohio state and then i put in oklahoma
so you know i could have easily one spot
up for grabs probably yes
and that was you know so it happened to
be notre dame it could have been
oklahoma one other school there there's
about seven or eight schools that can
play for a national championship
but just remember they'll be the first
if they win they'll be the first
unbeaten team in the
cfp era not to unbeaten power five
conference champion not to be in the
final four that's history
that's the wrong side of history they
better win tonight bill
yeah yeah
yeah there's always that possibility
they lose to oregon
uh i'm glad you're doing better it's
great to talk to you we appreciate your
time as always bill thank you very much
thanks dan anytime that's bill plaschke
la times columnist and espn around the
horn contributor